y miles y miles de personas participan
en la plaza de mayo- y aquí en sus
inmediaciones
exacto por la democracia y los derechos
humanos que conmemora 38 años del
regreso de la democracia argentina no
está aquí presente todo el arco político
nacional este un acto convocado por el
gobierno quieres estar aquí
instantes simpatizantes y organizaciones
afines a la coalición peronista del
frente de todos una coalición creen tras
la derrota de las elecciones
legislativas de noviembre
aquí está intentando mostrar fortaleza y
unidad seguridad porque están presentes
el presidente alberto fernández la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner de quienes a veces se dice que
hay cierto distanciamiento
entre ellos tres también una muestra de
fortaleza del progresismo
latinoamericano porque participan del
acto el ex presidente de uruguay josé
pepe mujica y también el ex presidente
de brasil lula da silva de quien hay
expectativa de que tal vez en algún
momento decida anunciar su candidatura a
la presidencia de brasil para 2022 y en
caso de que lo haga y en caso de que
resulte electo eso le daría un
espaldarazo regional al presidente
argentino alberto fernández quien
tendría un fuerte aliado en el gobierno
de brasil